como expresé antes.
Creo que se puede negociar siendo apasionado acerca de algo.
Porque al menos te importa.
Me gustaría creer que la palabra con c se ha vuelto
una palabra horrible, "compromiso", ¿cierto?
Tenemos la izquierda y la derecha extrema,
y el compromiso... olvídenlo.
Esos grupos ni siquiera quieren pensar en ello,
Pero hay una masa de votantes, incluyéndome a mí,
registrados como independientes,
como el 40 % de nosotros.
Hay una gran fracción de EE. UU. que quiere ver un cambio
y que quiere que la gente se una.
Solo tenemos que encontrar
la manera de hacerlo.
CA: Hablemos de eso por un minuto,
porque estamos teniendo estos diálogos TED para acortar brechas.
Hay mucha gente allá afuera, quizá de izquierda,
que piensan que esto es una mala idea
que la única respuesta moral a la tiranía
que quizá esté a punto de surgir en EE. UU.
sea resistir cada etapa, luchar con uñas y dientes,
es un error intentar hacer esto.
¡A pelear!
¿Hay algún motivo para eso?
DB: Depende de lo que "pelear" signifique. Si es pelear literalmente, no.
Si significa marchar, quizás, marchar para despertar consciencia,
está bien.
Pero si quieren cambiar este país, debe ser mediante partidos y política.
Organizamos partidos y estos son grandes coaliciones diversas y desordenados,
y participamos en política,
la política es siempre moralmente insatisfactoria
porque siempre se trata de un montón de compromisos.
La política es una competencia entre verdades parciales.
La gente de Trump tiene parte de la verdad en EE. UU.
Creo que Trump es la respuesta incorrecta a la pregunta correcta,
pero tienen algo de la verdad,
verdad encontrada en la epidemia de los opiáceos del país,
verdad encontrada en la propagación de la soledad,
verdad encontrada en la gente con vidas invertidas.
Alcanzaron el apogeo a los 30 años de edad
y van cuesta abajo desde entonces.
Así, entendiendo que no se necesita pelear
sino conversar y preguntar,
"¿con qué vamos a reemplazar a Trump?".
GC: Pero vieron peleas anoche, incluso en el discurso,
vieron a las mujeres demócratas que fueron vestidas de blanco
para honorar el movimiento sufragista.
Recuerdo que durante la campaña
algunos simpatizantes de Trump querían deshacerse de la enmienda
que permitía a las mujeres votar.
No podíamos creerlo.
No sé si esa sea la manera adecuada de pelear.
Fue interesante mirar a la audiencia
y ver a mujeres demócratas que no vestían de blanco.
Hubo muchas cosas ahí,
y muchas maneras de pelear sin necesidad de pelear.
CA: Una de las preguntas claves para mí es:
La gente que votó por Trump que pertenece un poco al centro,
como si fuesen susceptibles a la persuasión,
¿son más propensos a ser persuadidos al ver un levantamiento apasionado
de gente diciendo, "¡No, no, no pueden!",
o eso los enfadaría y alejaría?
DB: ¿Cómo somos persuadidos?
¿Voy a persuadirte diciéndote "Eres un fanático,
estás apoyando la intolerancia, estás apoyando el sexismo.
¿Eres el surgimiento fascista de algún pasado autoritario?".
Quizá eso no les parezca muy persuasivo.
Las maneras en que se persuade son:
a) una muestra de respecto básica respecto a tu perspectiva, decir,
"Creo que este tipo no te llevará a donde tú necesitas llegar".
Hay dos frases que han escuchado una y otra vez,
a donde vayan en el país.
Una, la frase "país de sobrevuelo".
Se ha escuchado durante años,
yo diría que este año, lo escuché casi cada hora,
un sentido de ser invisible.
Luego, el sentido de la frase "la corrección política".
Solo esa rebelión: "Ni siquiera nos dejan decir lo que pensamos".
Y yo enseño en Yale.
El estrechamiento del debate es real.
CA: Dirían que es una trampa en que los liberales han caído
al celebrar las causas en las que ellos creen,
a menudo expresado a través del lenguaje de la "corrección política".
Han hecho daño. Han alejado a la gente.
DB: Yo diría que el argumento es,
"descender al fascismo" "autoritarianismo",
que la gente siente exagerado.
He escrito ocho millones de columnas anti-Trump,
pero es un problema, en especial para los medios costeros
que cada vez que él comete un error incluso menor, hacemos alboroto,
y nos alborotamos cada día.
Eso dificulta la credibilidad hasta cierto punto.
CA: Dar falsa alarma muy alto y demasiado pronto.
Quizá haya un momento en que debamos dar alarma.
GC: Verán, una de las cosas más importantes para mí,
es cómo los medios conservadores manejan a Trump.
Cuando las cosas no sean ciertas, ¿las señalarán
o solo las aceptarán?
Para mí, eso es esencial en esta discusión,
porque cuando se tiene simpatizantes
a quienes no les importa si él dice la verdad o no,
podría ser muy peligroso.
Me pregunto, ¿Cómo van a responder los medios conservadores?
Tú los has desafiado.
¿Cómo van a tratarlo otros medios conservadores
en lo subsiguiente?
DB: Todo ha cambiado.
Los medios conservadores eran Fox, Charles Krauthammer o George Will.
Ya no son conservadores.
Ahora hay otro set de instituciones de extrema derecha,
Breitbart e Inforwars, Alex Jones, Laura Ingraham,
ahora ellos son la base, Fox ya no tanto.
CA: Mi última pregunta en este momento es respecto a la cuestión de la verdad.
Es una de las cosas más aterradoras para la gente ahorita,
no hay un acuerdo nacional sobre lo que es verdad.
Nunca había visto algo así,
donde los hechos son disputados de manera masiva.
Su periódico, señor, proporciona noticias falsas todos los días.
DB: Y con errores.
(Risas)
CA: Y con errores. Mis conmiseraciones.
¿Hay algún camino
por el cual podamos comenzar a llegar a acuerdos,
para creer en las mismas cosas?
¿Podrán las comunidades en línea jugar algún papel en esto?
¿Cómo lo arreglamos?
GC: Comprendo cómo ocurrió.
Fue otra oleada de emoción
que ocurrió en el centro de EE. UU.
sin ser escuchada,
creo que los medios dominantes fueron tendenciosos.
Aunque es distinto ser tendencioso a ser falso.
Esa distinción es muy importante en esta conversación.
Digamos que los medios dominantes fueron un poco tendenciosos.
Hay maneras de remendar eso.
Pero Trump lo está acaparando y dice,
"Miren, vamos a llamarle falso a todo".
Ahí se vuelve peligroso.
CA: ¿Creen que suficientes simpatizantes
sean más leales a la verdad que a cualquier...
Por ejemplo, el principio de no apoyar algo
que se ha demostrado que es falso
realmente importa, habrá rectificación en algún punto?
DB: La verdad eventualmente sale a la luz.
Por ejemplo, Trump ha basado gran parte de su política económica
en que se han perdido muchos empleos manufactureros
porque los chinos los han robado.
Es quizá el 13 % de los empleos que desaparecieron.
La verdad es que la tecnología reemplazó el 87 % de los empleos.
Esa es la verdad.
Como resultado, cuando él dice,
"Voy a cerrar el TPP y los empleos regresarán bulliciosamente",
no van a regresar.
Eso es un hecho, es mi creencia.
Y...
(Risas)
GC: Pero digo que lo que sus simpatizantes creen que es verdad,
sin importar cuántas veces lo digas,
ellos aún le creen.
DB: Pero finalmente los trabajos regresarán o no regresarán,
y en ese momento, o funcionará o no funcionará,
y si no funciona o deja de funcionar por un gran mercadeo,
funciona porque en verdad aborda un problema real
así que se me ocurre que la verdad saldrá a la luz.
CA: Si tienen alguna pregunta por favor levanten la mano.
Yael Eisenstat: Hablaré hacia la caja.
Mi nombre es Yael Eisenstat.
He escuchado mucho esta charla
sobre cómo necesitamos hablarnos más entre nosotros
y entendernos más,
e incluso he escrito y publicado respecto al tema también,
pero hoy en día sigo escuchando liberales --sí, vivo en Nueva York,
me considero liberal--
nos sentamos aquí para autoanalizamos:
¿Qué hicimos para no entender el Rust Belt?
O: ¿qué podemos hacer para entender mejor el centro de EE. UU.?
Y me gustaría saber:
¿Han visto algún intento o conversación del centro de EE. UU.
de cómo entender mejor a las élites costeras?
Porque me ofende que me clasifiquen solo como élite costera
como a alguien del centro le ofende que lo consideren estado de sobrevuelo
y que no se nos escuche.
CA: Muy bien, puedo escuchar el Facebook aclamándote...
(Risas)
DB: Yo diría --y habla alguien que ha sido conservador
toda su vida adulta--
cuando creces siendo conservador,
aprendes a hablar ambos idiomas.
Porque si voy a escuchar música,
voy a escuchar a Ted Nugent.
Muchas de mis bandas preferidas son de izquierda.
Si voy a ir a una escuela,
probablemente iré a una escuela donde la cultura es liberal.
Si voy a mirar una comedia
o un show de comedia nocturno, va a ser liberal.
Si voy a leer un buen periódico, será el New York Times.
Como resultado, aprendes ambos idiomas.
Y así, al menos por una cantidad de años,
cuando comencé en National Review con William F. Buckley,
nos hizo más mordaces,
porque estábamos acostumbrados a discutir con gente día a día.
El problema ahora es que hay como un ghetto en la derecha,
puedes vivir todo en el mundo de derecha,
por eso, la calidad de los argumentos de derecha ha disminuido,
porque no te pones en el otro lado
todo el tiempo.
Creo que si vives en Minnesota, Iowa o Arizona,
las élites costeras se vuelven visibles para ti,
así que conoces ese idioma también,
pero no a la inversa.
CA: ¿Qué es lo que el centro de EE. UU. no comprende de las élites costeras?
La crítica es,
no estás tratando con los problemas reales.
Hay un sentimiento de pedantería, un elitismo desmoralizador.
¿Qué se están perdiendo?
Si pudieran plantar una pieza de verdad
desde la mentalidad de alguien en esta sala, por ejemplo,
¿qué les dirían?
DB: Cuán fantásticos somos.
(Risas)
No, rechazo la categoría.
El problema con el populismo es el mismo que el del elitismo.
Solo hay prejuicio en su base,
o quizá una sobregeneralizada distinción de clases
la cual es muy simplista para aplicarse en la realidad.
Los que estamos en Nueva York sabemos que hay gente ahí
que es muy agradable, y otra que es patética,
y si vives en Iowa, algunos son agradables y otros son patéticos.
No es una cuestión de qué grado tienes
o en dónde vives en el país.
La distinción es una simplificación cruda para suscitar poder político.
GC: Me gustaría animar a la gente a ver las noticias
o a leer una columna que no leerían normalmente.
Y si eres simpatizante de Trump, mira al otro lado un día,
porque necesitas salir de la burbuja
si quieres tener una conversación.
Para ambos lados; si eres liberal,
mira algo que sea conservador.
Lee una columna que normalmente no leerías,
porque así adquieres perspectiva de lo que el otro lado piensa,
y ese es el primer paso para estar unidos.
Me preocupan lo mismo que a ti, esas burbujas.
Si solo miras algunas instituciones,
no tendrás idea de lo que está hablando el resto del mundo.
DB: No solo se trata de mirar,
sino ser parte de una organización que se reúna una vez al mes
que te ponga en contacto directo con gente totalmente distinta a ti
es responsabilidad de todos.
Quizá esté un poco errado,
pero los modelos de autos que más se venden en el país,
los tres o cuatro primeros son camionetas.
Pregúntense: ¿cuántas personas que conozco tienen una camioneta?
Podrían ser muy pocas incluso cero para mucha gente.
Ese es un signo de alerta.
¿Dónde hay un club para unirme
que tenga mucho en común con una persona que maneje una camioneta
porque tenemos un interés común en algo?
CA: El internet contribuye en esto.
Una pregunta de Chris Ajemian:
"¿Qué opinan de que las comunicaciones,
en especial las redes sociales y el contenido individualizado,
puedan ser usados para unir una división política,
en vez de guardar comunidades en cámaras de eco?".
Parece que Facebook y Google, desde la elección,
han trabajado duro en esta cuestión.
Han intentado cambiar los algoritmos
para no difundir noticias falsas
porque pasó la última vez.
¿Ven alguna otra señal prometedora...?
GC: ... o difundir un lado de la ecuación.
CA: Exactamente.
GC: Creo que ese ha sido el argumento constante de la derecha,
que las redes sociales y el internet en general
pusieron artículos a la cabeza que no eran su visión del mundo.
Considero que eso alimentó el enojo.
Alimentó el enojo de:
"Están promoviendo algo en lo que yo no creo".
Las redes sociales lo han cambiado todo obviamente,
y Trump es el ejemplo de que Twitter ha cambiado absolutamente todo.
Desde su perspectiva,
él se ha acercado a los estadounidenses sin ningún filtro,
el que para él son los medios.
CA: Pregunta de la audiencia.
Destiny: Hola. Soy Destiny.
Tengo una pregunta respecto a la corrección política:
¿Cuándo la corrección política se convirtió en sinónimo del silencio,
frente a la manera de hablar de otras personas
para mostrarles respeto y preservar su dignidad?
GC: Creo que los medios conservadores afectaron esta situación
en los últimos 10 años.
Emplearon realmente mucho tiempo
hablando de la corrección política,
y cómo la gente debía tener la habilidad para decir lo que pensaba.
Otra razón para que Trump se volviera tan popular:
él dice lo que piensa.
También me hace pensar en el hecho
de que mucha gente en EE. UU.
está de acuerdo con Steve Bannon,
pero no lo admitirían públicamente,
y votar por Trump les dio la oportunidad
de estar de acuerdo silenciosamente.
DB: Sobre la cuestión de inmigración es un punto de vista legítimo
que tenemos demasiados inmigrantes en el país,
eso es económicamente costoso.
CA: Que tenemos demasiados...
DB: Inmigrantes en el país, en especial de Gran Bretaña.
(Risas)
GC: Como que me gusta el acento británico.
CA: Me disculpo. EE. UU., lo lamento.
(Risas)
Me iré de inmediato.
DB: Ya no es permitido decirlo,
porque se volvió una señal de que eras un fanático de algún tipo.
La corrección política no solo se estaba poniendo dura con los discursos
que todos encontramos completamente ofensivos,
sino también con discursos legítimos,
y pasó del discurso y el pensamiento a la acción
y lo tachó de crimen,
mucha gente fue despedida, o expulsada de las escuelas,
y se escribieron reglas de discurso.
Ahora hay grupos diversos,
donde si dices algo que alguien encuentre ofensivo,
como, "fumar es peligroso", pueden decirte "nos estás insultando",
y el equipo administrativo vendrá a la puerta de tu dormitorio
y te pondrá a un policía del pensamiento.
Se ha reducido considerablemente lo que es permisible decir.
Algo de eso a veces es legítimo.
Hay ciertas palabras que deberían ser sancionadas de manera social,
algo de eso se usó para imponer una agenda política.
CA: ¿Es ese un proyecto
que se instauraría en los liberales, --o progresistas--
para reconsiderar las reglas básicas de la corrección política
y aceptar un lenguaje un poco menos incómodo
en determinadas circunstancias?
¿Creen que eso se resuelva
al punto de que otros no se sientan ofendidos?
DB: Muchas universidades de EE. UU., en especial las de élite,
son en demasía de izquierda,
y hay una tentación
de usar su gran poder cultural
que pensarían es justo y correcto.
¿Hay que desconfiar de uno mismo o, eso está pasando?
Por otra parte, mi universidad, la Universidad de Chicago,
envió una carta diciendo que no tenemos lugares seguros.
No habrá crítica de microagresión.
Si hieren tus sentimientos, bueno, bienvenido al mundo de la educación.
Creo que esa política
--la cual es ser acogido por mucha gente de izquierda, por cierto--
es un correctivo de lo que ha ocurrido.
CA: Karen Holloway tiene una pregunta:
¿Cómo adoptar una cultura estadounidense
que tiene miras al futuro, como Hamilton,
que ansía y maneja el cambio,
en lugar de querer regresar a un pasado ficticio queriendo tenerlo todo?
Es una pregunta fácil, ¿no?
GC: Bueno, soy un creyente del sueño americano,
y podemos enseñarle a nuestros hijos lo básico,
o sea, que con el trabajo duro
y con creer en ti mismo
en EE. UU., puedes alcanzar lo que quieras.
Me lo decían todos los días.
Cuando llegué al mundo real, pensé, oh, quizá no sea del todo verdad.
Pero aún creo en eso.
Quizá sea muy optimista.
Y espero que en el futuro aún sea así.
DB: Creo que eres demasiado optimista.
GC: ¿Lo crees?
DB: La probabilidad de que un joven supere el salario de sus padres...
un 86 % de la generación pasada lo logró.
Ahora el 51 % lo logra.
Hay un problema de movilidad social aquí.
CA: Has escrito que todo este siglo ha sido un desastre, básicamente,
que la edad de crecimiento se acabó y que estamos en verdaderos problemas.
DB: Sí en promedio a escala de población
hemos crecido un 2 o 3 % en 50 años,
y ahora menos del 1 %.
Algo se nos está escapando.
Si le voy a decir a la gente que tome riesgos,
estamos viendo un declive acelerado en la movilidad
en el número de gente cruzando las fronteras estatales,
es cierto en especial entre millennials.
Es gente joven que me mueve menos.
¿Cómo le damos a la gente la seguridad de que pueden tomar riesgos?
Creo en la teoría del apego para criar hijos,
y ésta tiene por lema
que la vida es una serie de aventuras riesgosas vividas desde una base estable.
¿Tus padres te han dado una base estable?
Como sociedad no tenemos una,
y no podremos llegar a ese ethos enérgico y riesgoso estilo Hamilton
hasta que proveamos una base estable.
CA: Me pregunto si hay razones
para crear una agenda compartida, un diálogo para acortar brechas,
por una parte, reconociendo que hay un problema muy serio
que el sistema económico que creamos,
parece fallar en estos momentos.
Por otra parte, si están en lo correcto de que no son los inmigrantes,
sino más bien la tecnología,
si pudieran ganar ese argumento,
que atenúa lo que me parece es el único y más divisivo territorio
entre los simpatizantes de Trump y los demás, que es el rol de los demás.
Es ofensivo para la izquierda satanizar a los demás
al punto en que aquéllos sean realmente vistos como tal.
Esto se siente en demasía inmoral,
y quizá la gente de izquierda concuerde, como mencionaste,
en que la inmigración ha pasado muy rápido,
y que hay un límite más allá de lo que la sociedad puede manejar,
sin embargo, este problema se atenúa
si la automatización es el punto clave,
y trabajamos juntos reconociendo que es real,
reconociendo que el problema no fue apropiadamente abordado
visto o escuchado,
y encontramos cómo reconstruir comunidades
usando, ¿usando qué?
Esa parece ser la conversación fértil del futuro:
¿Cómo reconstruir comunidades en la edad moderna,
con la tecnología haciendo lo que hace,
y reimaginar un futuro brillante?
GC: Por eso recurro al optimismo,
no soy... no es que no mire los hechos,
a dónde hemos llegado o de dónde venimos.
Pero, por Dios, si no miramos desde una perspectiva optimista...
me rehúso a no hacerlo.
No estoy educando a mis hijos de 12 y 13 para que digan "el mundo es sombrío".
CA: Tomaremos otra pregunta de la audiencia.
Interrogador: Hola, hola. Disculpen.
Ambos mencionaron que el plan de infraestructura y Rusia
y otras cosas no son prioridades tradicionalmente republicanas.
¿Cuándo creen que los republicanos se animarán
a pronunciarse en contra del trumpismo?
GC: Después de lo de anoche, no en mucho tiempo.
Mucho cambió anoche, creo yo.
DB: Su popularidad entre los republicanos, tiene el 85 % de la aprobación,
que es más alto de lo que tuvo Reagan,
y es así porque la sociedad se polarizó más.
La gente sigue al partido mucho más de lo que solían.
Si esperan que Paul Ryan y los republicanos en el Congreso
se desprendan,
va a tomar un tiempo.
GC: Pero también porque a todos les preocupa la reelección,
y Trump tiene tanto poder poniendo gente a favor
o en contra,
que vacilan cada día, quizás:
"¿Debo o no debo estar a favor?".
Anoche, cuando al fin sonó como presidente,
los republicanos deben estar respirando aliviados hoy.
DB: Esa media vida es corta.
CG: Cierto. Eso iba a decir, hasta Twitter pasó otra vez.
CA: Bien, quiero darles una oportunidad
para que imaginen que están hablando con --no sé--
la gente en línea que está viendo esto,
que quizá apoyen a Trump,
o que sean de izquierda, o de centro.
¿Cómo les aconsejarían acortar brechas y relacionarse con los demás?
¿Podrían compartir su sabiduría en esto?
O si creen que no deban, díganselo.
GC: Quiero comenzar diciendo
que cualquier cambio y unión viene de arriba,
como en cualquier organización.
Me encantaría que un día,
los simpatizantes de Trump, o la gente de derecha, animaran a sus líderes
a mostrar compasión desde arriba,
porque imaginen el cambio que podríamos tener
si hoy Trump twitteara,
para todos sus simpatizantes,
"No seamos malvados con nadie más.
Entendámonos más.
Como líder, seré más inclusivo
con toda la gente de EE. UU.".
Para mí, comienza desde arriba.
¿Va a hacer algo así? No tengo idea.
Pero creo que todo comienza desde arriba,
y el poder que él tiene
para alentar a sus simpatizantes
a comprender de dónde viene la gente del otro lado.
CA: David. DB: Sí, yo diría
que no creo que podamos enseñarles a otros a ser civiles,
y dar sermones de civilidad.
No funcionará.
Es la substancia y nuestro actuar,
lo bueno de Trump es que rompió nuestras categorías.
Todas las categorías que creíamos tener, están obsoletas.
Fueron buenas para siglo XX. No lo son para hoy.
Su agenda se trata de cerrar las fronteras y el comercio.
No creo que vaya a funcionar.
Si queremos reconstruir comunidades, crear empleos,
necesitamos otro tipo de agenda
que termine con nuestras actuales divisiones y categorías.
Esa agenda es el reaganismo o política macroeconómica,
En Suecia su política de bienestar
trasciende a la izquierda y a la derecha.
Debemos tener una economía dinámica para estimular el crecimiento.
Es la política económica de Reagan.
Pero la gente necesita una base estable.
Necesitamos asociaciones de enfermeros y familias;
preescolar universal;
debe haber escuelas subvencionadas:
debe haber programas universitarios envolventes
para padres y comunidades.
Necesitamos ayuda para sanar la crisis de solidaridad social
y ayudar a curar familias,
el gobierno tiene que involucrarse más
en la manera en que a los liberales les gusta reconstruir comunidades.
Necesitamos tener la economía libre y abierta
que solía gustarles a los conservadores.
Si la substancia es la correcta podemos atravesar
las identidades partidistas,
porque la substancia forma nuestra polarización.
CA: David y Gretchen, muchas gracias
por una absolutamente fascinante charla.
Gracias. Fue muy interesante.
(Aplausos)
Hay que continuar esta conversación.
Tratamos de encontrar
si se puede agregar algo más,
continuemos la charla por Facebook.
Díganos qué piensan desde su postura política, cualquiera que sea,
y desde donde se encuentren en el mundo.
Esto no solo se trata de EE. UU., sino de todo el mundo.
Terminaremos hoy sin música,
porque si ponemos música en cada charla de política,
el mundo sería un lugar distinto, créanme.
Lo sería simplemente.
(Aplausos)
Esta extraordinaria mujer del Harlem,
Vy Higginsen, quien se encuentra aquí...
veamos una toma de ella.
(Aplausos)
Ella creó un programa que une a los adolescentes,
les enseña la alegría e impacto de la música góspel,
y cientos de adolescentes han estado en ese programa.
Es transformador para ellos.
La música que componen, como habrán escuchado,
es extraordinaria,
no se me ocurre una mejor manera de concluir este diálogo TED
démosle la bienvenida al Coro de Góspel del Harlem de Vy Higginsen.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Cantando) Coro: Oh hermosos y amplios cielos
Por olas de grano ámbar
Por majestuosas montañas púrpura
Arriba de un llano frutal
¡América!
Dios derramó su gracia sobre ti
Y coronó a tu Dios con la hermandad
Desde el mar al mar radiante
(Aplausos)